So as we just saw, plain, old
variables in Swift do not allow nils.
But in some situations,
we want to allow for nil values.
For situations like these,
Swift has a special data type.
It's called the optional type.
What is this optional data type?
An optional is like a wrapped
box that might be empty.
That's the option.
It might have a value or
it might be nll.
Whenever you specify
the optional data type,
you also give the type of
the value that might be inside.
So we make a distinction
between Int optionals, and
String optionals, UIButton optionals,
and AnyObject optionals.
But it's really only one generic
data type, the optional.
We can't use optionals
without unwrapping them.
In this equation,
the box represents an int optional.
It might have a value or it might not.
We can't tell until it's unwrapped.
So now we come to the real
challenge with optionals.
How do we use question marks and
exclamation points to declare and
process optionals?
[SOUND]